you can't see my face but my eyes are
like this big right now
one of my colleagues flagged a story
about this American fencer who was going
to be the first American athlete to
represent at the Olympics and he job as
I started to learn more about its gaucho
Mohammed I just became really fascinated
with her
if jiangshi tweets a lot both about her
athletic accomplishments but also casual
instances of Islamophobia one of the
most notable ones was when she was at
South by Southwest in Austin Texas when
she went to go register and get a badge
she was told that in order to take a
photo that she needed to remove her
hijab it's pretty ridiculous
that was a really telling experience
that millions of Muslims around the
country have have experienced so
recently I was invited to an event in
which if Yas Muhammad this incredible
fencer that I've been following for the
past four months who's going to teach me
how to fence you really could poke out
an eye I suspect that fencing is going
to be this really interesting
combination of like yoga and ballet but
also Mortal Kombat we're gonna do a
short fencing demo we actually have to
change in a locker room I thought I
could just throw the stuff on over my
clothes
here we go putting on the fencing gear
you can't see my face but my eyes are
like this big right now the target area
is from the waist up and we use flashing
motions to scorer points someone's like
modern-day Zorro right
you wanna like figure this is a lifelong
dream of mine so to have it finally come
true it's just probably the best moment
of my life honestly I wanted Team USA to
be as diverse as the community I grew up
in or the American that I know but the
Muslim community has always been really
supportive of me even before I qualified
for the team now that I'm able to be you
know the speaking of light for my
community I think that it'll move you
know
the perception of Muslims in a positive
way Wow talking to God finally being
able to meet her he's really awesome
really like Drake loved Rihanna's new
album she's a Drake and Rihanna fan
which is really really good to know and
I think she's gonna do some great things
give me one sec can we take a quick like
two second selfie yeah filter it so I
look cute